so when it comes to making youtube
videos that are interesting and
compelling for your audience to want to
watch one of the key ingrediences is
storytelling and i'm excited to bring my
friend katie quesada on the show today
to break down what a storyteller does
and how you as a content creator can
start to include more stories in your
videos all that more coming up
hey what's up it's heather torres here
with the youtube made simple show where
we're helping you overcome fear build
confidence and launch your successful
youtube channel and today i have my
friend katie casada on the show now
katie has been speaking and teaching at
conferences for over a decade and in
that she's helping people learn how to
storytell she is a compelling
storyteller coach and i met her recently
at an event and she blew me out of the
water with the way that she can connect
stories with content creators and so she
is on the podcast today we're going to
jump right into the interview but before
we do i want to let you know that we
have a brand new youtube class if you
have not taken our free class about how
to get started on youtube and get your
first 1000 subscribers and beyond you
definitely want to register for that at
thinkmasterclass.com alright let's get
into today's featured conversation with
my friend and storyteller coach katie
quesada
[Music]
well katie i am so excited to have you
on the youtube made simple show today um
you and i met actually at a conference
recently where you did such an amazing
job on stage really talking about how
our stories matter and i was like i need
to bring you on the show because so many
content creators disassociate themselves
from their content and when you can
bring in your story when you can talk
about your past experiences and really
help to align that through your business
um you really can
get to know your your customers your
viewers can get to know you so talk
about how you even got into the story
world the storytelling world yeah
totally
so five-ish years ago i was a part of a
large organization and we would do these
events every month in-person live events
and we'd bring in speakers i'd speak at
them i've been speaking for years that
was kind of the vibe and then one one
event we brought in this amazing woman
named dr tama bryant davis out of
pepperdine university and she stood on
the stage on a friday night at this
event and she said i was backstage
sitting right behind the curtain and she
said did you know that there's a barnes
and noble of untold stories here in this
room
and i felt this like really radical
conviction that i wasn't supposed to
speak there anymore and i wasn't
supposed to bring in speakers i was
supposed to teach people to tell their
stories so it was a little bit
nerve-wracking because i knew it was
true like in my gut but also i was like
am i putting myself out of a job and is
anyone going to want to come back to
these things like they were successful
events at that point i was like am i
going to crash the truck um but i knew
it and i knew it was right because we
did have an auditorium filled with
incredible people and i knew that and so
i flipped the script and then for the
next three years behind the scenes every
other month
i would coach three people of very
diverse backgrounds ethnicities ages
stages all of it to tell their story in
six minutes their life story usually
around a theme so like advocacy hope joy
grit hustle and then they would tell
that story in six minutes so i did that
over and over again this was a very
small part of my job actually it was
kind of like a hobby part of my job and
then when i knew it was time for me to
quit my job i was gonna leave that
organization and at the same time wildly
my husband and i were selling everything
and moving into an rv full-time
um somebody said to me aren't you gonna
miss speaking at those events and i said
no i'm gonna miss coaching at those
events and it was it was when you like
say something out loud and at the same
time you realize it's true even though
you said it so i was like oh yeah that
is a thing and so like three years ago
now
i said i'm a storytelling coach and i
just started to tell people that and i
made it up
and then for the first year it was like
slow building and then now super
thankfully three years later it's
thriving and it's been a gift and i help
people in companies tell better stories
so sometimes that's like a fractional
chief marketing officer for a high level
company and sometimes that's sitting
across from somebody and listening to
their story for an hour and just telling
it back to them in five minutes and
that's crafting it together so it's
individual coaching corporate coaching
speaking all of those things i just
think about stories all day long so
that's what i do for a living i am so
excited to break this down especially
for content creators because a couple
years ago um when sean and i started
doing our web classes that led to the
products that we were selling a big part
of it actually was to be able to tell
our story inside of what we were
packaging so that people could actually
relate to we've been where you are and
we know the solution and it was so
illuminating to me on like how much our
brand story matters and these little
pieces like you just said that you uh
did tiny living then youtube made simple
show uh viewers know that i'm obsessed
with all of us and so those little
pieces where we can connect with each
other and be able to to have something
that allows someone to know like and
trust us so i want to get into for
content creators for youtubers how does
this look like what would be what is a
brand story um for them yeah so if
you're a personal brand story like you
are the face of something you are the
main part of something
you have to tell your story you need to
be able to share that story and talk
about who you are now i know that that's
kind of like tricky and feels a little
bit like maybe is that too much
information but what's important here is
that you
know how to talk about moments in your
life and things that have shaped you you
do not need to tell the entire story let
me tell you you do not need to come on
and do a 19 minute youtube video on here
is my story you really have to do the
hard work of whittling and condensing
and concising the information in order
to evoke emotion and really meet with a
brand and when that i mean meet with
your brand values when that happens it's
really successful
yeah and when i think about youtubers um
and when they're creating videos you
know for us here we're creating videos
on lights and microphones and youtube
tips but people know our values because
we'll talk about those moments where
i'll say something like you know the
hardest season of my life was really
when we were forty thousand dollars in
debt and i wasn't successful in anything
yet and i couldn't figure it out you
know those types of things like that one
sentence becomes such a connector so i
want to walk through um
why do brand stories work you know when
you think about content creator they're
making 10 minute videos 20 minute videos
5 minute videos
15 second instagram stories how do you
make the the story work into you know
product-based content or into um you
know content that may not be just
storytelling content yeah so there's
amazing research about storytelling i
mean unbelievable never-ending research
if you want to go down a rabbit hole go
down that rabbit hole
but i'll come up out of the rabbit hole
for you and just show you a little bit
of it but there's this incredible study
out of the university of ohio where they
put 100 people in one room and 100
people in another room and in each room
they presented the same information but
in one room they gave facts and in the
other room they told a story but it was
the exact same information
100 of the time the storytelling
persuaded or created a change of opinion
faster than the fact
so the story works worked 100 of the
time faster um yes the facts may be in
the end supported the cause or helped
the story um storytelling neurologically
and physiologically aligns like heart
rates there's incredible research about
how storytelling engages us it
captivates us and really for a person
who's creating content um there's a
there's a
buzzword that's funny but the truth is
what you're trying to do is make
something that resonates with someone
but how do you do something that
resonates what do we mean by that word
oh that resonated with me what's weird
is what it what you're what you're
really trying to say is i kind of
thought about myself when i was
listening to that
and when you can help someone think
about themself you're telling a really
good story really great speakers really
great storytellers for some reason in
the middle of their talk you're like my
dad was like that too
oh i also do that you're not consciously
thinking those thoughts but you're
having a warm feeling that feels very
good and you're feeling this feeling of
resonating so you want to create moments
where your audience can resonate with
you and that happens through
storytelling come up with micro stories
exactly like you just said like
the hardest season of my life was
that's a great story sentence
let's start there that is a great
content creating video that is a great
amount of people to know because they
can resonate with you they can feel that
we've all had hard stories and for a lot
of content creators there is a real
i think we have to feel this pressure to
have really like everything really tied
up and great and like perfect
and so we come on and we think like oh
so last year i made a million dollars
and everything's great guess what that
story doesn't resonate with me right it
doesn't so now i have a story that
doesn't resonate with you even though
you might think that that's helpful the
truth is you have to create moments that
resonate with people so so good in uh
one of the uh classes that i teach i
talk about how the first time i talked
on stage which was a virtual stage i had
my arms like this because i but my
armpits were sweating so much so if i
move my arms and literally people in the
comments will be like oh i remember when
you talked about your pit sweat i'm like
glad to be known for that but it's
relatable and i think you know uh um in
the book that i just wrote i interviewed
a lot of different content creators and
one of the things that uh content
creators who were scared to launch or
scared to really go all in on youtube um
they were scared to put their
personality or to put themselves out on
camera and they were like i will be a
robot and just make the video and it's
like just be you just be normal but also
bring in those stories like pit sweat
that are relatable in everyday life so
how would a content creator like how do
we do this what are the actual tangibles
of like finding our brand story and do
you brand's story is quote unquote
personal story like you said you don't
have to share everything and i believe
you shouldn't bleed on people like if
it's not healed probably don't share it
you know just hold on to that um
but like how do you tangibly figure this
out like what should you share yeah so
if you are if you are running a company
or you have a product you are selling so
if the story needs to be product based
then you need to tell a compelling story
where you solve a problem and where your
customer is the hero
so this is incredibly important in all
great brand strategy storytelling you
are never the hero your customer is the
hero you are the helper so
i
there is a mom and she's having a really
hard time getting her kid in the bath
and then she found these amazing glow
sticks that she throws in the bath and
now her child loves bath time and she's
having the time of her life
see in that micro story i just told
about the glow sticks in the bath the
mom is the hero in the end the glow
sticks helped her she is that they are
the helper we have a really big tendency
to become the hero of the story
the truth is in great customer-based
storytelling if you have a product then
the customer needs to be the hero now if
you're a personal brand and your content
is you and your own story then you have
to do the work to mine some life events
that have values attached to them so
this is a little bit of what i shared at
the conference that we were at together
but um the difference between a micro
story and a macro story so for a lot of
people we are trying to come up with
this like specific event and have that
one event really shape everything that
we do so for example i sit across from a
client and the client says to me
oh kati i'm a cancer survivor i survived
cancer i have stage four cancer i want
to talk to cancer survivors because
that's very specific cancer it's all
about cancer
and like that's great what did you learn
from the cancer
and then after some work together she
can say
oh i learned resiliency
and now her story is about resiliency
and a story about resiliency is one i
can come into a story about cancer i
can't
so we actually want to open the doors as
wide as we can by turning macro stories
micro stories into macro stories and how
you do that is you attach a value to an
event
so look back on your life and say the
hardest season of my life was that what
i learned was this
look back on your life and say what i
learned about that was humility or
authenticity or purpose or passion
and finding these value words and you
can google like value words and honestly
a great activity is to google value
words then circle some of them and then
just write a story about what happened
reverse engineer it to kind of mine some
of your stories um just so you can
continue to really make the story as
wide as possible and to let as many
people in as possible yeah and i think
another piece one thing that i learned
super early on in my online career um
was that uh always bring honor
always bring honor so no matter if you
are if you if you're in a situation and
a problem happen with someone and don't
bring gossip bring honor to whatever
that situation is because there is
always a better way to project a story
um that doesn't
pull down other people so i love what
you said to uh katie that everyone has a
story so someone might be listening
right now and they're like i'm here to
get youtube tips and heather's bringing
me a storyteller but the reason for it
katie is because everyone has a story
and one of the the the mandates i feel
like is on my life is to help people get
in front of cameras and start telling
those stories get your message out there
get your voice out on video yeah i would
like you to just encourage some people
right now who maybe feel like you know
this isn't for me i don't really want to
talk about myself
it's so important so can you just give
some encouragement to people um who
maybe not space yeah i think one of the
great lies that we believe um is that
stories are created for comparison uh
like oh she has a she has a much more
important story than me so i
i'm not gonna tell my story because her
story is crazy um and that is a massive
lie that i think is really unhelpful
because stories actually are good in
masses
so it's so important to remember that
almost all of us are narratively shaped
by multiple stories
so almost all of us are shaped nearly
right now because a lot of different
people told the same story from a
different vantage point
so we actually don't need a couple great
storytellers
we need a lot of medium ones like that
is radically what the world needs and i
think that's true of platforms i think
that's true of the internet i think
that's true across the board like
for all of us we actually need a
collective of storytellers we don't just
need like one super story so when you
can see your life that way it's not like
oh she has a more amazing story than me
wow she's way more important than me wow
he made way more money so nobody needs
to hear my story
that's actually unhelpful because what
we need is way more versions of whatever
story inspires us so we need a thousand
we don't need one so
as we tell more and more and more
stories it really does shape narratives
and change the world
oh i'm just getting so fired up because
to me i just i love telling people like
youtube needs you they need
your story they need your gift they need
you exactly the way you are you do not
need to change you do not need to
compare and so i love that so much all
right i want to shift gears and go
practical how do content creators how do
youtubers how do they practically put
this into their content how do you grow
into this and what does that muscle look
like how do we get there yeah
so you want to evoke emotion and you
want to do something say something kind
of memorable these are some of our
takeaways but you also want to do it in
a way that is concise so that
conciseness is probably the hardest part
um because for a lot of us we've
storytelling is a skill we've never been
taught we've never even thought about
we've never honestly even thought about
it one time you know and i say all the
time in the work that i do the question
is not if you're a storyteller or not
you are
you are always telling stories the
question is just do have you ever
thought about them so you no matter who
is listening you're a storyteller you
have to you have to deeply and innately
believe that because it's true you you
are telling stories about your kids
about your family about your job about
your passions about where you're from
about your hometown about what scares
you these are all stories
so when you can see yourself as a
storyteller that's kind of step one um
then step two would be start to do some
research to figure out what parts of the
story are the most compelling and where
can i condense it so some of the work
that i do is that there are people who
are really detailed like specific and i
have some workshops for this too where
we work through like what type of
storyteller are you and then how do you
get better but for some people they just
have way too much context like they
would start their story with like it was
1997. and i was wearing yellow and oh
sorry it was wednesday no it's thursday
oh shoot you know what i'm gonna call my
my brother real quick and find out if it
was tuesday and i'm like none of this
matters like everything you just said i
need to go like six minutes into the
future um and it's just way too much
context so context actually only needs
to be a tiny bit these days um what we
need way more of on the heavier end is
compelling and often conflict or climax
like what's happening and how do i get
there wow um so we kind of need to lean
more into that range
so i think you can start by just
answering some story based sentences
like
the hardest moment of my life was
what i took from that was
i'll never forget what i felt
differently about
something that i've realized makes me
unique is
one thing that really resonates me with
me is and you just kind of start to
finish those sentences um but a great
activity is to take is to give yourself
only one paragraph and to write a
compelling story for yourself
um you might actually have to start with
writing a page and then cut it in half
but if you want because you might get so
tripped up in the first sentence like
what is my story it is very hard
honestly another thing is probably so
much of what you do
it's shockingly difficult to talk about
yourself mm-hmm people talk about a
product all day you can talk about a
brand all day you can talk about your
the weather all day but when it comes to
like just you
doing the work of learning how to talk
about yourself is such a gift because it
will always serve you across the board
in all networking branding storytelling
connections like what do you do why do
you love it why does it matter and
that's a great initial brand story
wow katie so many good takeaways i think
an action item if if you're watching
this right now is to grab that piece of
paper and start writing out your story i
think those those prompts are a great
way to start katie if they want to go
deeper with you learn more about the the
work that you're doing right now to help
business owners to help entrepreneurs to
help content creators learn how to tell
their stories uh what are some ways that
they can connect with you
yeah my website is katiekasada.com my
instagram is the same my instagram is
almost only stories so i i very rarely
post
you're only using stories on your
story over anything else um and then on
my website katiecasana.com i have an
e-course called own your story and in
that you can identify seven key moments
from your life and that will help you
identify values and you can kind of
start to think through wow what is this
brand story how do i say this in a
sentence is this compelling how does
this feel what does this look like and
you can start to kind of dial in
so so good katie thank you so much for
your time today for coming on helping
the youtube made simple viewers uh learn
how to really express themselves more in
their content to be able to uh bring
more of the stories that matter to the
world to help people understand that
their story matters yeah and i'm just so
honored that you took the time today to
bless us with this so thank you so much
yeah it's been so great and one more
thing i just was thinking about that i
forgot um in my encouragement for your
team and your people and everyone you're
listening um you just need to tell the
truth
and i think that that is kind of a
forgotten point in storytelling because
we try to make a story something it's
not um but you actually just get to tell
the truth and when you tell the truth
about your life and what happened and
how it really felt
um that really does birth a beautiful
story so sometimes my clients i just
start with tell me the truth about
something that maybe you've been
avoiding
tell me the truth about something in
your brand tell me the truth about a
problem you solve tell me the truth and
just those words alone evoke a feeling
that often connects to a brand story in
a way that is really compelling no
matter what the product is no matter
what if it's you like what is an area of
your life where you just want to tell
the truth and that might be the birth of
a really compelling and captivating
story
wow i got goosebumps when you started
saying that because it is the it is the
thing right it's just be just just tell
the truth tell me how it happened and
that is where people will resonate right
back to that word again that's where
people will resonate because it's real
because it's honest and because it is
your life story so katie let's end it
there because that was amazing thank you
so much for your time today and i'll
link everything down below question for
you uh in the comments below let us know
what is the next story you're going to
tell where where are you gonna put it in
what content um i'll be in the comments
and i'd love to read those so make sure
you post those down in the comments
below if you like content like this make
sure to subscribe so you get all of the
action happening over here on the think
media podcast channel and if you've not
yet signed up for our free youtube class
you can do that at
thinkmasterclass.com we'll help you get
started on youtube today thanks so much
for watching and we'll catch you in the
next episode
you